joining us now is new hampshire governor
chris sununu governor welcome to fox
news sunday
good morning brother
sir i want to start with the cdc
external review out this week finding
deficiencies in their covet 19 response
they admitted they have at times put out
confusing guidance to say the least now
they're planning an overhaul to become a
more
rapid response public health agency
you've been a governor navigating this
pandemic is that enough for you do you
think with this they can rebuild public
trust
do we really need a taxpayer-funded
external review to determine that the
cdc is all over the place i mean for the
last two years
they say one thing they do another they
tell us one thing privately they do
another uh these guys have been
constantly backtracking and and so i
guess the only good takeaway here is
they're acknowledging it i think they're
starting to realize that we are really
out of this pandemic we're moving
forward as a country uh local control
and local decisions are best made by
parents and families and so you know we
are we gonna have coveted surges coming
of course we are but we have those tools
now we have the vaccine we have
therapeutics we have all these tools in
our toolbox now
so yeah i guess it's great that they're
finally acknowledging it but it's
something that the rest of america has
acknowledged for the last 18 months yeah
and the reason i talk about public trust
sir is because it's only a few months
ago that the cdc director also came out
and said listen when we said to follow
the science we never said the science
was exact and my response would be well
you kind of did say the science was
exact and those who failed to comply
were all listed as at least from the
left were all listed as public health
threats
look when
officials come out from the national
government and talk about science
there's an implied understanding as a
guy that went to mit and and you know
studied a lot of science and engineering
when you say the word science you're
saying data you're saying we know what's
happening we understand it and here's
the response that we need you cannot
come back out and say something totally
different down the road because it most
importantly we don't want to have the
cdc have people have no trust in the cdc
we don't want that but unfortunately
that's that's where we are today as a
governor i was on those calls with the
cdc director we're on the calls with the
white house we'd hear one thing on the
phone something totally different what
happened the next week mass confusion so
as the governors during the height of
the pandemic we really had to buckle
down and do what was best for our
citizens and make our decisions we kind
of listened to what they said
okay i hear you but this is what we're
seeing on the ground and we had to make
decisions for our citizens i think
overall governors did did a very very
good job uh at least in the in the red
states um i can't speak for some of
those blue states with all the excessive
lockdowns because again they just kept
doing whatever the white house and the
cdc was telling in one week and then
shifting the next week eroding trust
with uh with what should be a really
responsive branch of government yeah and
you talked about children earlier the
cdc is also out with new cova guidelines
for schools just as kids head back to
the classrooms they no longer recommend
routine testing for grades k through 12.
unless of course community transmission
is high do you support that change
governor
yeah look the locals locals and schools
and parents have to make the decisions
for themselves i live in new hampshire
where they live free or die state we
believe in local control we believe in
in in schools making those decisions for
themselves not having the federal or
even the state government come down and
push certain answers onto them and
certain protocols onto them so
especially where we are now knowing that
we have all these tools in the toolbox
knowing that folks are working
collaboratively with their school
districts collaboratively with parents
to understand what these issues are yeah
that is local control is definitely the
right approach yeah and the other major
back to school story this week is the
big teacher shortage uh in the u.s
nationally we're talking about 280 000
countrywide fewer teachers than there
were before the pandemic but it's
interesting because in new hampshire in
your state you have actually renewed
more education credentials this year so
what is exactly driving the trend
nationally and what are you doing
different in new hampshire to have
different results sir
well well nationally whether it's
teachers nurses there's a couple of
professions here that are just
absolutely burnt out and we we
understand that nationally after what's
happened over the past couple years um
in new hampshire we're different we
really heart are if you may on that
local control we work collaboratively we
don't fight it you know we put more
dollars in public education for students
than ever before and we pass school
choice right and we're creating more
opportunities for kids in public schools
to get credentialed in a you know a
workforce type environment that they
want to enter into it we're not just
doing things traditionally and when you
support that local aspect and you you
inspire creativity you let teachers have
some have some say working with those
parents local control is really the
answer anytime the government gets
overly involved in education it normally
doesn't go well and so we take that kind
of pushback approach we believe in
parents and teachers teachers now want
to be here we're the only state in new
england that's actually growing in
population businesses are flooding in so
you know we've really focused on the
individuals individual towns individual
schools that allows i think a
kind of rising tide floats all boats
here in new hampshire and that's why
look we have the strongest economy in
the country where we in the first
quarter of 22 we're one of the only
states with a positive gdp so everything
is driving forward in a positive
direction we don't get caught up in the
in the overly political
aspects of things uh you know glenn
young had it right parents matter right
and teachers matter they all matter and
they have to work collaboratively we've
been able to foster that here and we're
very proud of the fact that we've been
able to actually increase the number of
teachers over the past couple years
interesting you used the phrase creating
opportunity i want to get your take what
do you make of florida governor ron
desantis proposal to recruit military
veterans and first responders without
teaching degrees to help fill those
vacancies down in florida
look
i i love the asp the idea of focusing on
military focusing on veterans focusing
on folks with real world experience you
know you get them into those classrooms
you get them into a job you go through
the credentialing process there are
states out there where if you want to be
a teacher it literally takes years to be
credentialed even if you've been one
before right because they have their
whole process and rigmarole so
streamlining the regulatory and
permitting and certification processes
whether it's teachers or manufacturers
that's an opportunity that every state
has we're doing it here we're
streamlining our whole thing i think our
reciprocity we have with places like
massachusetts and maine and vermont
makes it very easy for folks to come
over the border which is one of the
reasons why we're growing so i love the
concept
the country has workforce shortages
let's stop
making let allowing government get in
the way of getting these people on the
floors in in this classrooms whatever it
has to do to give them a job and get
kids or get the product out and that's
what it's all about it's not about the
system it's about the kids yeah i want
to change gears here to the midterms to
new hampshire politics incumbent
democrat senator maggie hassan is up for
re-election the gop primary weeks away
right now polling has retired general
don baldwick leading you said this week
that baldock is a conspiracy theorist
who really threatens your party's
chances at winning back the seat are you
concerned is there a worry in your party
that the the gop could be missing out on
a golden opportunity here
well senator hassan's gonna lose in
november there's no doubt about that she
has spent 25 million dollars her
approval rating hasn't moved i hope she
spends 100 million of the democrats
money because it's going to go up in
flames here
you know we have seen other races across
the country we've seen national
discussion that when you elect the wrong
individual it makes it much harder to
win in november right you have to have
good candidates quality candidates at
the end of the day whether you're
running for the planning board you're
running for governors u.s senate or
president you got to get quality
candidates that can cross the line
winning in a primary is nothing means
nothing you can't govern if you don't
win in november and that's all that
matters and i focus on winners and i
want the best candidate that can win i
want the candidates that have the best
shot at beating maggie hassan to make
our lives a little easier um and so
that's why you know i'm focusing on
other candidates frankly because i don't
want in to happen to new hampshire what
we've already seen happen in other
states where that that gap becomes just
too big you're seeing it in pennsylvania
unfortunately in georgia i still think
those republican candidates can win i
think they're good candidates but
they're having a much harder time of it
than they frankly should have in what
should be a a wipeout year nationally
the problem is this we are talking about
things that aren't mattering that don't
matter to the voters the voters care
about kitchen table issues they care
about high prices they care about
inflation they care about you know
having options for their kids in schools
and we're still i mean mar-a-lago is a
very important issue in january 6 what
happened there is very important but
those aren't driving folks to the polls
those aren't driving folks in the voting
booth and so we got to get back in a
media social media and our kitchen table
discussions and if we do that
republicans across the board can be very
successful yeah you talk about you know
politics here former vice president mike
pence visited new hampshire this week so
did republican senator tom cotton take a
look a huge roster of potential 2024
candidates have visited your state in
recent months i mean it's a great state
to wonder why they're coming we're
talking about cheney
go ahead yeah there's a couple outside
the studio waiting to talk to me right
now
i'm sure
we've got chris christie ted cruz nikki
haley mike pompeo tim scott i mean it
really the list goes on it's a long way
to 2024 getting a bit crowded in the
grand estate they're knocking on the
door trying to get you to help them what
do you make of this have you talked to
any anybody about why they're coming to
new hampshire
oh yeah no i talk to all all the
candidates that want to come i'll
happily sit down with all them but my
focus is this if we don't close the deal
in 2022 as republicans across this
country you don't close this deal in 22
24 ain't gonna matter we gotta start
focusing on closing this deal making
sure we cross the finish line with good
candidates winning back the senate i
think we're gonna get the house but the
senate instead of being a guaranteed 54
is new hampshire could be that 51st vote
now and i think it's going to be but we
really got to make sure we close the
deal the other issue is you gotta how we
campaign here is a little different you
gotta look people in the eye the running
joke in new hampshire is hey are you
gonna vote for for president trump well
i don't know i've only met him twice
right you've got to be able to integrate
with folks on a one-on-one level in
their living rooms in their businesses
and if you do that you can be very
successful i'm kind of like the referee
if you will the referee yeah the referee
who is also very popular in his state it
looks like your race is going very well
my question to you is have you talked
with any donors about 2024
uh you mean in terms of
in terms of what like who who they're
going to be supporting yeah people
donors come up all the time and say well
what do you think of this candidate or
that candidate yeah uh maybe you're
running for something else governor i
mean are you concerned you have all
these people coming in and they've all
seen the same thing you know if chris
sununu runs for president that changes
the whole dynamic dynamic right it
when you talk changes
visiting anything it's it is true yeah
i know
no look it's all flattering people are
talking i get it but 22 that is my
message to everyone in this country stop
worrying about 24 stop worrying about
who's running for president let's all
focus get out knock on doors pick up the
phones that has to be done then we'll
have plenty of time for 22 and as we all
know politics moves quickly what hap
what the the political landscape today
is gonna be totally different just one
year from now and even that will be six
months before the first in the nation
primary of new hampshire so we got a
long way to go yeah you have often said
you mentioned january 6 you mentioned
mar-a-lago you have often said that you
are not anti-trump but many have also
said you have been somewhat of a thorn
in the former president's side and while
he was in new hampshire former vice
president mike pence touched on the
backlash after the fbi searched
mar-a-lago here he is watch yeah
our party stands with the men and women
who serve on the thin blue line at the
federal and state and local level
and these attacks on the fbi must stop
calls to defund the fbi are just as
wrong as calls to defund the police
what do you make of the search of
mar-a-lago sir and of this fierce
backlash
so couple things i think the biggest
issue is what we've all been talking
about the fact that when you're going to
go into a former president's house yet
clearly biden and garland they had no
strategy no anticipation about saying
we're going to take unprecedented action
so we better have an unprecedented plan
for disclosure and the fact that we're
weeks in now they're not showing any
cars they're not showing anything the
lack of transparency it's infuriating
and that is where they have absolutely
blown it and that's where they've lost
the trust of the american people because
it just looks political they didn't
strategize i get this whole thing that
well you don't want to disclose things
if it's an active investigation that
should have been thought thought out
before if they didn't anticipate this
type of response from the american
people well they're morons they really
are they're absolute fools because you
cannot walk into a former president's
home raid his home like that and then
say well we'll get back to you later not
acceptable to the american people so i
think vice president pence mike pence
he's by the way great guy um has done a
phenom did a phenomenal job as vice
president and he's absolutely right we
should be talking about defunding police
and fbi we're republicans we support law
enforcement every single time but the
strategy at the top has been a disaster
and they have to own that
new hampshire governor chris sununu
governor thank you for your time this
weekend we appreciate it
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight